[Music]
John wick has deleted scenes from the
sum of all fears on his phone they left
him for dead even he left himself for
dead but then he didn't die
therefore this movie's most subtle title
screen ever I mean if I'm walking in
blind that could be the directors name
or the lead actors name or production
logo is it just me or could this scene
serve as the darkest Gillette
advertisement ever she hated my beard so
now I'll shape it for her ghosts pretty
sure Bridget Moynahan is playing a dead
character in this movie and will only
appear in brief flashbacks like this one
and I can't help but wonder if that's a
good gig or a gig you get when you're
washed up John's wife collapses and then
dies in the hospital despite the movie
never telling me what's wrong with her
I suppose I'm left to guess hmm I'll go
with diphtheria no if JJ Abrams had
directed this I'd be feeling all the
emotions right now as it is I'm mostly
just feeling nothing every umbrella at a
funeral is black cliche also it's a
funeral so of course it's raining cliche
I mean no we're missing here is an
evanescent song right movie will make
wick seem like a total loner but at the
same time this many people came to his
wife's wake that's a lot of people yet
someone can shipped him a dog John I'm
sorry I can't be there for you but you
still need something someone to love
apparently this chick had in her will
the dog would be purchased and sent to
her husband along with this letter and
all that would be kept secret from her
husband until it happened I'm just super
confused and I mean what animal shelter
offers this service will deliver a
straight is someone that didn't ask for
it and will also deliver a sad letter
from a dead loved one only $59.99
meanwhile while John cries this poor
puppy has peed his carrier like three
times and is ashamed look up in the pot
dog oh what a good boy I'm taking off a
sin for this goddamn good boy oh wow
6:00 a.m. the puppy woke him up at the
same time his normal morning alarm goes
off what are the odds milk and cereal
for a dog granted he wasn't expecting a
dog last night so maybe he doesn't have
anything on hand okay
but you still don't feed a dog milk and
cereal in that instance right I mean I
feel like this is what pee-wee Herman
does not a real person
also who ships a dog to some
unsuspecting person without also
shipping some goddamn puppy chow maybe
if you don't take your new dog with you
on your car ride he doesn't die you ever
think about that
yep the entire movie is going to hinge
on the coincidence of these gangsters
randomly stopping at the same gas
station as John wick and Theon having a
hard
for king with strangers the stages of
grief are denial anger stunt-driving
bargaining depression and acceptance
they killed his dog these guys are worse
than actual Theon oh wait Leon burn kids
alive never mind forget what I just said
but does it still fucked up also the
easiest way to get the audience on your
protagonists side is to have the bad
guys kill his dog works even faster than
killing a wife or a kid
doing this instead of just killing him I
mean you broke into his house you killed
his dog you're stealing his car well I
leave him alive there's no good reason I
can think of except a movie needs to
happen also who wants a car this badly
you want the car so instead of just
stealing it you break into the owner's
home kill his dog beat his ass but leave
him alive then steal the car this plan
was created by one of the Horrible
Bosses characters right if you are this
sad about your new dog being killed
don't can hold it up to your face and
pet it like Buffalo Bill bury that and
go on a revenge tear like a normal human
Oh
Keanu just realized he's being filmed
wrong movie has Keano ride and dismount
a city bus without any overt speed
references I give the movie props for
restraint even while ice in it for that
same restraint what yo cetera self-
lethal son as it happens John wick
actually already knows the father of the
fucker who killed his dog considering he
bumped into that dude at a gas station
just before the attack that's a massive
coincidence John wick lost his Mustang
that borrows a Chevelle and before all
is said and done I bet he also drives a
charger for the American muscle car
trifecta are you struck my son poor
Alfie Allen just has a face that screams
needs his daddy to fight his battles for
him Oh
Viggo employs the all-state mayhem guy
which can only lead to mayhem it's not
what you did sons with Angus be sir it's
who you did it - ooh nobody but nobody
is John wick if you know John wick by
sight and you no one would be a danger
and your chop shop guy knows him by
sight shouldn't your king son know John
wick by sight - John wick gave up his
old killer lifestyle but only so much as
to bury it under the basement floor in
case of emergency it takes John so many
sledgehammer swings to get into this
floor thing I'm left wondering why I
didn't just buy a fucking safe father I
can make this right it's amazing how
much of this guy's dialog could
literally be replaced with Theon dialog
from Game of Thrones without anyone
noticing
thankfully the father of the guy that
killed John Wick's dog has John Wick's
home landline number in his rolodex John
week is the kind of man that showers and
dresses in all black before exacting his
revenge because he's a cinematic
very all this house is made of 75% glass
these bad guys apparently didn't hear
any of the gunshots in the other room
from the previous scene movie assassins
always wear suits which look great but
isn't very practical real assassins
probably wear sweat pants but they're
much easier to move it I'll leave you be
then John good night Jimmy thankfully
for John he has an unexplained
understanding with this local cop
wherein dead bodies on John's floor will
be ignored so long as John remembers to
get Jimmy 50-yard line seats for the
next Raiders game or some he was willing
to foe making a veggie drink good for
him for being healthy this movie though
for thinking I give a shit about this
characters diet movie expects me to
believe there are hitman offices inside
New York City's famed Flatiron Building
in addition to the Daily Bugle
operations how much data do you think
John wick is paid for watching his dead
wife videos over and over but he gets
throttled near the end of every single
month will be joins in solidarity with
Breaking Bad and insisting evil crime
people do most of their business and
dry-cleaning facilities and on Wednesday
this movie's ian mcshane characters
excessively older Andy Garcia for some
reason not gonna lie John wicks gear up
for a fight scene is as good as any gear
up for a fight scene ever filmed I'll
remove us in this club is expecting John
wick the club knows a super assassin is
coming here to fuck up and it still
stayed open like how much money are you
making nightly for this to be a logical
decision just close the club and fill it
with all the henchmen you have give John
wick a fight right
instead the club is all I need those
extra dollars you so we shall hash this
out on the dance floor among drunk
college students the typical who do odd
sets do stylize subtitles make a movie
better or worse discuss a nightclub has
showers and locker rooms are you telling
me this is actually a sex club fine what
kind of whore house has showers and
locker ropes murderer in a reflection
apparently makes no noise whatsoever or
else this vain guy is also death sink
drowning though I'm actually sending the
scene for the fact that the victim
thankfully filled this sink to the
goddamn brim before Rick showed up
creating his own death pool ecovida sure
he's already in the club killed the dude
and is down in the bathhouse but i'm
surveillance so the answer to your
question is no this is awesome and cool
but still he wastes time shooting this
asshole in the chest three times before
shooting him in the head John wick is a
bullet waster I'm sorry to say Deadpool
will be proud for a few seconds John
wick turns into a goddamn stormtrooper
club music is so loud folks can't even
hear dancefloor gunshots honest question
how many highly-trained henchmen willing
to die for the boss's kid over murdering
world's greatest hit man's dog does this
crime family actually have imagine the
payroll they have to be a billion dollar
enterprise El Chapo money if you're
gonna headshot this dude why waste the
time to do the beard grab head slam bull
is it just for show I think it's just
for show wit gets his ass kicked by a
random Club henchman which survives this
fine he survives it without major spine
damage you in the ear movie sniper turns
out to be helping John by alerting him
to the female assassin by shooting his
pillow and yeah shooting the pillow is a
pretty good I need to warn you now but
don't have the time to call you signal
but what would be even better would be
to shoot and kill this assassin chick as
she's entering the room am I wrong
I really don't think I'm wrong here how
many rings does it take before this
concierge actually takes any action
priest cursing John wick is up here on
the not that high roof watching these
fools do an execution my question is
aren't there tons of roofs and windows
where non John wiki and people might see
the head shot execution committed in
broad daylight that pillow haulage it
did nothing to quiet that gunshot that
was loud as hell this doesn't
incapacitate John wick long enough for
him to be killed somehow this is the
main bad guy and wick is right here and
yet we're still 35 minutes from the end
which means some kind of a miracle is
gonna happen to keep wick from getting
to this guy
these guys don't double tap wick right
though now for some reason
aka revenge aka screenwriters discretion
oh they're gonna torture him first of
all good luck with that
second of all for what reason or
information what does wick know that you
want to get out of him he wants to kill
you because your outfit killed this dog
that's pretty much it just torturing him
gain you people don't change you know
that unless their wife dies and someone
kills their puppy those folks might
change just a little bit no which is why
God took your wife whoa dude multiple
party fouls here bringing up the dead
wife suggesting God took her for John's
misdeeds suggesting God exists I
received some semblance of an
opportunity to grieve on the law he's
talking about a dog though just FYI of
all the king ways to kill a do these
henchman gun with a freezer bag over the
head for suffocation method which is not
only known to be a long method of murder
but also carries the added weight of
tainting the ziplock name-o and giving
the hero time to escape good thing the
boss man left before all this am i right
Willem Dafoe mix machina also helpful
sniper only Snipes one of the bad guys
giving us this fight that is largely
unnecessary regardless of how cool it
might seem let's have
ass hand-to-hand fight like those Jason
Bourne movies right down to the choke
out ending but let's make ours slightly
worse in every way really up three dudes
killed in the last ten seconds yet these
henchmen are still loyal to Theon
because I have no idea I'd have cut and
run ages ago natural and Dean will be
bypassed for a longer more drawn-out and
unnecessary ending because movie using
your smartphone while driving John wick
just accidentally created a PSA I
appreciate you granted my son a swift
death well give him a chance a sudden
wound opposed being tortured seen his
sudden my son
this scene is shooting holes in my
Willem Dafoe is evil prediction so I
don't like it
two shots to kill him then three to four
shots for spike all this time he's been
listening to the bad guy telling him and
kill people but only after the death of
what's-his-name does John wick violently
jerked the car around in a 180 okay yeah
you got this car for free and but still
leaving it unattended with the keys
inside anywhere in New York City is
basically Tugg Speedman levels of stupid
based on the actions of literally
everyone they obviously do not live by
any code whatsoever thank God that
mysterious can I call and told wick the
word helipad thank God he knew exactly
which one of NYC's many dozens of
helipads to go to after such news and he
was given a free hot rod so that we
could finally have a finale and end this
thing it's amazing how much of this
hand-to-hand and gun badass movie spins
its finale focusing on driving skills
who's that a gun asks the main henchman
of the main bad guy who should be fired
immediately for such a lack of
situational preparedness none of these
machine guns firing a Twix car appear to
do any good whatsoever they don't stop
the car they don't hit wick why haven't
they shot out of stars yet rushing us us
it's Neal versus the allstate mayhem guy
you have five seconds to place your bets
and I hope you use common sense whit
kills a dude with the car but his lack
of spatial awareness is astounding hole
deep it levels a bull oh my god is it
raining since when no more bullets no
more
lowitz let's let fisticuffs decide this
especially since you're 60 years old and
wick takes more than five seconds to
eliminate this geriatric bad guy John
wick aka Jesus
aka neo aka seeing you John the great
thing is Vigo's death and the collapse
of his criminal empire will result in a
power vacuum also that would probably
lead to a gang war a lot more people are
about to die because I guess he wants
medicine wick breaks into an animal
hospital at the end of the movie mostly
so he can find a dog that's about to be
euthanized so he can save it and make
all the animal lovers in the audience
forget his other puppy's traumatic debt
[Music]
John I'm sorry I can't be there for you
but you still need something someone to
love
[Music]
you can save money and be better
protected from mayhem avenge me